قبل بدايه المباراه وقريبا من الملعب
هؤلاء الشابات الايرانيات رفعنا لافتات
محظوره في ايران يريدنا مواصله التظاهر
حتى في الدوحه لن ادعم هذا الفريق لانه
فريق النظام نريد ان يرفض اللاعبون
الايرانيون غناء النشيد الوطني الفريق
الايراني وقبل مباراته مع انجلترا تضامن
مع المتظاهرين ولم يغني النشيد الايراني
دون حجاب تضامنا مع مواطنهم داخل ايران
اما في ايران ستقيموا السلطات حمله جديده
في المدن الكرديه مجموعه هنكاوي الحقوقيه
قالت ان القوات الايرانيه قصفت خلال الليل
مدن فلان شهار وماريان وجوان روت المنظمه
نفسها افادت بان قوات الامن قتلت اكثر من
10 اشخاص خلال 24
شهر تم اطلاق النار ايضا على اشخاص كانوا
يشيعون القتل في جوان وغيرها التشيع تحول
الى مظاهره ضخمه منظمتها كاو قالت ان
مواجهات حاده حدثت بين المتظاهرين وقوات
الامن واصيب عدد من الاشخاص فيها حسب
منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران مرحله جديده
تدخلها البلاد مع تشديد الحمله الامنيه من
السلطات في مهابات مجموعات حقوقيه قالت
انه تم ارسال تعزيزات الى قوات الامن فيها
المظاهرات استمرت في كراما شاه المتظاهرون
هتفه الموت للمرشد الاعلى للجمهوريه علي
الخامنئي